hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure mal
wann und willkommen zu diesem
wunderbaren tastest Video und heute
werden wir richtig nostalgisch Kelly ist
auch da
und wir haben darüber gesprochen wie
unsere Eltern uns früher Fake Produkte
verkauft haben also wenn wir etwas
gegessen haben und gesagt haben oh mann
aber warum kriegen wir nicht das
Markenprodukt dann haben Sie immer den
Spruch gesagt es kommt eh alles aus der
gleichen Fabrik also es liest sich so
als könnte das auseinander der gleichen
Fabrik gekommen
und dass wir
Ding als
Kissen mussten und unsere Freunde und
alle anderen hatten die originalen
deswegen haben wir gedacht weil es schon
100 Millionen Menschen auf Youtube
gemacht haben machen wir heute einen
original vs doubt
und wir haben Produkte ausgewählt die
wir auch wirklich aus der Kindheit
kennen und konsumiert haben und die wir
nicht im Original essen dürfen und wir
werden heute ganz genau sehen schmeckt
es gleich und können wir es erraten kann
ich wirklich erraten was das Original
ist was ist das Fake Produkt ist
ey was wenn du vielleicht sogar besser
als es original bin noch nicht so früher
ich würde sagen wir fangen mit der
ersten Mahlzeit und damit auch mit der
wichtigsten des Tages an Frühstück
im ganzen Tag einmal Kellogs einmal
knusperone die Fake Produkte haben wir
bei Aldi gekauft weil meine Familie
immer bei Aldi eingekauft hat und die
originalen Produkte gab es teilweise
auch bei Aldi
du darfst nicht gucken weil ich muss die
Produkte so stehen lassen damit ich weiß
welches welches war was ich meine und Du
darfst ja auch also du musst mich
füttern okay
Schüssel kommt oder so schon immer deine
Fantasie
also du guckst jetzt gar nicht ja
und Action das erste kommt jetzt
amazing wirklich sehr gut ich weiß warum
ich das gefrühstückt habe
so Nummer zwei
bin ich gespannt was du sagst du ich
habe beim ersten schon gedacht das sind
Kindheitserinnerungen aber als ich das
zweite probiert habe und die Härte darin
geschmeckt haben ich würde sagen das
erste waren die Snacks das zweite ist
das Fake was hat dir denn persönlich
besser geschmeckt das erste war süßer
das zweite war nicht so süß das zweite
hat tatsächlich gesünder geschmeckt
einfach nicht so zuckig okay
das erste war das
meine
Mutter hat und wer macht gelacht das ist
was wenn es du besser schmeckt oh mein
Gott
unterschiedlich machen die halt
überhaupt keine Unterschiede
aber Aldi ich dachte richtig so ja ich
habe es rausgefunden
du machst
so genau das mit
einem machen wir weiter
[Musik]
los Bremen
das ist die Königsdisziplin ja man sagt
ja man kann Nutella nicht nachmachen ne
das ist ja so ein Ding das schafft
keiner mäßig ne aber deine Augen zu du
musst das Glas eigentlich hier vor der
Kamera einmal so
das ist die Nummer 1 da kommt der kleine
Flieger
das ist die Nummer 2 hier
ja mein Liebchen was sagst du das ist
eine ganz klare Antwort das kann man
wirklich nicht Fakten Nummer 2 war die
Nutella richtig
komisch das ist keiner hinbekommen ne
ich weiß doch sie schmeckt schon besser
aber die erste schmeckt irgendwie so
lustiger und Schokolade egal und
irgendwie eigentlich viel wertvoller als
die Nutella aber weil Nutella da
verbindet man einfach viel mehr mit
Nutella Crêpes auf dem Jahrmarkt die
rero Produkte mit Nutella gefüllt
aber ich glaube das liegt daran dass
Nutella das ist fast Palmöl benutzen ne
benutzt aber eine Mischung
und Sonnenblume und ähm Nut nur Palmöl
das brauchen wir einen kleinen Snack zum
Neutralisieren was salziges hier muss
ich wirklich einfach nur entscheiden was
besser schmeckt weil ungarisch mit
Paprika zu vergleichen ist natürlich ein
bisschen
ja aber hä aber unglaublich ist doch
Paprika oder schon nächstes Produkt
Numero Uno
für mich wenn der Kirche schon was dazu
sagen schmeckt lecker
krass ich war mir so sicher dass der
erste Chip der ungarisch war okay und
dann habe ich den ungarischen schmackel
Geschmack geschmeckt ja Nummer zwei war
ungarisch ne aber ich war mir das
irgendwie ich habe den ersten war so oh
ja das sind die ungarisch
haben sich die von Aldi verbessert ich
habe das Gefühl gehabt früher waren die
Sachen die viel fettiger aus wie du sind
super
süßer Paprika gewürzt so mit edelsüßen
Paprika gewürzt
die Paprika ich würde jetzt noch auf den
Preis natürlich ne wenn wir 1,99 € für
die Paprika Chips und 1,99 € für die
Idee das ist 1 € teurer also ganz
ehrlich die sind so nah dran vom
Geschmack haha da würde ich sagen
soll dich anders ein bisschen ich habe
ich habe jetzt richtig Durst bekommen
ich weiß genau was du Lust bekommen hast
auf Flirt
[Gelächter]
oh das kann gut numero
da ist ordentlich Aroma hinter mir ein
echter konnossa gestört
ja nicht so gut das ist die Nummer 2
krass die Nummer zwei schmeckt im
Vergleich zur Nummer eins so süß das ist
schon viel zu süß schmeckt okay kannst
du mir den Vergleich vom Zucker sagen
von der Nummer eins und der Nummer Zwei
eins hat 7,6 Gramm Zucker die Nummer
zwei hat 7,6 Gramm Zucker what also ich
glaube die Nummer 2 war die Fanta falsch
ja eins war Fanta 2 war du
manchmal ist das wahre Wesen der Dinge
schwer zu erkennen die Nummer zwei war
Fanta
was ist es nun wirklich ich dachte ich
bin mir wieder so sicher dadurch dass
man es nicht sieht ist es so ein ganz
anderes Erlebnis was passt perfekt zu
einer Fanta eines super leckere Pizza
bitte time aufgefallen Kinder ständig
gegessen haben oh ja Kandidaten Nummer
eins kommt angeflogen hast du einmal
deinen Mund so ein bisschen so irgendwie
so dran gehalten ob es heiß ist
der Boden war richtig hart durch
junge
das ist hier das Restaurant
ja
trifft dich die sehen halt komplett
verschieden aus auch ne es war schon
Grund warum in der Restaurante Werbung
immer die beiden so in so einem schönen
Ort saßen und die hat mich tolles Leben
mit Pizza restaurantte so wir gehen
wieder in die dessert-sektion das ist
ein sehr emotionales Ding für uns nur
damit ihr Bescheid
auf der einen Seite ein Snickers oder
auf der anderen Seite die guten alten
peanutsitzige genauso schmecken wie das
ist eine krass
schon ne ich weiß nicht ob ich also ich
kann mich erinnern dass die du nie so
richtig ans echte Snickers dran gekommen
sind ich weiß nicht wie es bei dir ist
das Hirn spielt dann natürlich auch viel
vor und vielleicht war es immer nur die
Verpackung die dann einem das Gefühl
gegeben hat ja das ist besser als das
ist
[Musik]
also ich würde mich jetzt schon fast
verstehen
beschreibe mir was du denkst ich
weiß es ich weiß es nicht ich weiß es
nicht ich habe nicht mal eine Vermutung
ich also mir den ersten was darf ich so
das ist mir egal beim zweiten habe ich
mir gedacht das ist mir egal ja ich
würde bei meinem Gefühl bleiben ich
glaube der erste was ja Snickers war
Nummer 2
vor allem jetzt zeige ich dir mal
folgendes weißt du warum ich denke dass
das erste das war weil es perfekt war
die Schokolade war super der die Nuss
war richtig schön aromatisch und crunchy
und mal guck mal wenn du jetzt vom Look
her guckst ne kann ich mal vom Look her
sagen welches den Snickers und welches
denkst du das Felds nee das ist das äh
Pina
auch noch
mit der Ecke gegen den Joghurt Chris
das ist das erste
ja ist gut lecker oh sehr leckere
Schokolade ein guter Crunch sehr leckere
Schokolade Produkt Nummer zwei
der Joghurt schmeckt nicht so vanillig
der Crunch war aber besser also mir
schmeckt Produkt Nummer eins besser
wegen dem Joghurt aber Crunchies von dem
zweiten waren besser jetzt muss ich
sagen bis zur original was ich glaube
wegen dem Joghurt weil der irgendwie
besser schmeckt Nummer eins war das
Original herzlichen Glückwunsch Vanessa
du hast dein erstes so richtig erraten
an die Nutella hatte ich auch richtig
mit einmal für euch Leute um diesen
Moment zweimal das tollste als Kind
oh nice okay wir sind beim ganz
kompletten
nachts gegangen Milka und Alpen
Milchschokolade Nummer eins
toll
super super
weil der zweite so schmeckt wie früher
die Schoko Weihnachtsmänner geschmeckt
haben die ich bekommen habe und jetzt
kommen wir zur absoluten Meisterklasse
das was glaube ich uns am Herzen auch
teilweise am meisten weh getan hat ne
dieses verdammte als gottlos das ist
nicht Magnum hört auf ist Magnum zu
nehmen
Nummer eins
das war ein geiler Sound echt lecker
[Musik]
ist schon gut das erste war mir mal
genommen
Magnum das erste Mal das Magnum
irgendwie war die Schokolade cremiger
das Eis der Crunch das war das
Gesamterlebnis war einfach angenehmer
als beim zweiten beim zweiten war es
irgendwie dünn so okay also das erste
ist Magnum und diese Antwort ist
absolut falsch das erste was Sensation
das zweite Warnung das muss jetzt aber
auch mal probieren ich habe noch nie ein
gutes Magnum du gegessen und ich habe
einige probiert
lecker
ich bin ich bin einfach sprachlos gerade
weil es wirklich manche Dinge sind
einfach in meinem Leben die stehen so
fest ja wir sind Opfer von Marketing
meistens ne das muss man einfach
feststellen an dieser Stelle ja und von
diesem Denken ja klar es ist ja die
original Marke oder das ist ein Marke es
muss besser sein das ist ja das Original
das ist teurer das ist hochwertiger ich
bin schockiert was lernen wir aus dieser
Geschichte hört auf eure Eltern auch
wenn sie manchmal reden aber trotzdem
wenn alles nicht in der gleichen Fabrik
hergestellt